a couple things I did not get to this
week
um my pillow founder and CEO Mike
Lindell
was coping with the mounting losses on
Tuesday by simply saying it's all stolen
it is all fraud as it started to become
clearer and clearer on Tuesday night
there's no Red Wave there's like a
delayed red Ripple maybe and we're still
waiting for some of the results the
victory Channel brought him on I have no
idea what that is they said sir Mike
pillow please explain what's happening
and Mike pillow said listen they're
they're stealing everything that's
what's going on Mike tell us what's
going on by the way the idea of even
asking pillow what's going on is
hilarious they do here's what he says
well it's uh it's it's kind of what I
expected um they're stealing everything
um just did Herschel Walker's race alone
over 200 000 votes have been injected
into his opponent they've been injected
like bleach folks these are obvious
how many times you know it how many
times can they repeat the same stuff and
people will fall for it injection now
votes to get to this runoff stage uh
they stole the governor's race in uh
with mastriano in Pennsylvania no
mastriano simply lost she an early
injection of 90 000 votes by the
computers at Kerry Lake they're trying
to steal her so everything is stolen
everything is stolen this is really the
epitome of brain worms but it's also the
epitome of
if you have a hammer and all you have is
a hammer and you believe the hammer is
almost like a god
everything is a nail and this is all
they have left the truth
is not something they can accept the
truth is Trump hasn't been particularly
good for the party
one in 2016. 2018 wasn't so good 2020
wasn't good at all and 2022 was much
worse than expected it's not fraud it's
not injections or sauteing or grilling
or smoking or curing ballots it's not
salting and peppering of ballots it's
not it's not any of it
Trump is convincing these voters to
select terrible candidates for the
primaries a lot of them are now losing
it's genuinely that simple and they are
throwing anything they can at the wall
and now what it is is the epitome of if
we won it was rigged
if we lost I'm sorry
if we won it was fair if we lost it was
rigged even on the same ballots and
that's one of the funny things you know
a few people emailed me
over the last couple of days about what
I tweeted years ago now about how is it
that they're saying on the same ballot
the presidential results were rigged but
the Senate and House results are
trustworthy when Trump lost but their
house or Senate candidates won and it's
starting to be the exact same level of
incoherence again why anybody would go
to Mike pillow for analysis I genuinely
don't know
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you are
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David Pacman show by getting
your next mattress from Helix sleep and
and you'll get up to 350 off any
mattress plus two free pillows when you
go to Helix sleep.com slash Pacman the
link is down below